The Kids Are Alright well not according
to them and they're making sure we know
about it for the past month children
across the world have been cut in class
to get us to cut down on pollution it's
not often that I encourage young people
to miss school
however with temperatures on the rise
and freak weather a regular occurrence
it's time to face up to the severity of
the situation wearing someone's
definitely needs to give these adults a
good talking to step up 16-year old
Swedish activist Greta Thornburg the
leader of the protests who made
headlines when she read the global elite
the riot act at this year's World
Economic Forum in Davos as she said we
must act now some more than others and I
agree with her those who've profited the
most from exploitation of the earth
should be held the most accountable it's
time for the privileged few to start
paying off the debt of the many Oh to
mother nature and if the Davos crowd
myself excluded darling haven't realized
this by now they're maybe they're the
ones that should be back in school
because when it comes to the planet the
kids are so right I mean the issue is it
seems simple in that it's do you think
kids should come out of school to
protest yes or should they be at school
which is more value to them one day it's
a protest to make this important point
which is absolutely about their future
100% they should come out school to play
yeah I I think I probably agree with you
but I don't think it's clear-cut Oxfam
as you put our statement which I think
we affected by position better say okay
we are ball kids being out of school but
climate change means that one day many
may not even have a school to attain
anyone whose very existence is under
fetch at least have the right to speak
up about it
to our children climate change is not an
abstract idea but a frightening
threatening reality and I suspect that's
fair and I do think you'd hate the idea
that the kids came out of school every
week to put
well of course so what you're saying is
there are odd occasions when it's when
it's worth a valley which I said I
probably go along with but I don't think
it's if if this was everything tidy oh
no way no can I just ask the obvious
question yeah because I think it's
wonderful that they're engaged in
climate change and I fully support their
words hmm why not just do it on a
Saturday exactly I think it's much more
impactful of them all taken the day of
school I think the politicians know I
would if there was a mass protest at the
same time she's all over the world you
know I think I like Michelle I think
it's great to that they're getting
involved but don't ask me to believe
that all of them on that March we're
doing good for that reason some of them
weren't wagon off school I think and I
and I heard one of the strike or not
them I heard one organizers say this is
one day but I'll change the world bless
them I don't well I don't want to pay on
what they've done it's not gonna change
the world it will make me difference and
I think that we reached a pitch here in
this country because the younger
generation has seen the political class
completely consumed and absorbed with
ranks in the last thousand days on a
subject that is that also going to
probably impact on their futures and
they're absolutely hoppin yeah that the
older generation the you know the over
50s over sixties over 70 so basically
stone in their futures and they very
much resist the accusation that they're
playing truant because yeah you know
they want to do it in school houses
let's hear from one of them I don't
think it will impact on my education
because I'm willing to do the couch at
work I'm not striking from school today
because I want to miss a day of school
I'm striking because I have no other
option and I do still value my education
and I don't see the point in having an
education if what they're teaching me is
not sufficient if what they're teaching
me is not accurately portraying the
severity of the crisis our future needs
imminent environmental reform in order
to protect it I don't understand why the
government don't recognize that and the
takeaway from all this student protest
is that if we're get we need to cut
greenhouse gas emissions by forty five
percent if we're not going to see the
global temperature rise by one point
five percent with untold consequences
for everybody yeah the towel is also I
think that some of those kids will go
out because it's fun but actually that
said you cated yeah
they'll understand about climate change
in a way they do one of my neighbours
actually said to her 15 year old girl
okay I get you you do your engagement I
think that's really good so you can you
go on strike but she said I tell you
what what is this here we let we as
you're so concerned about we won't go on
a holiday because you have to take a
plane to go to Spain or wherever and and
that's that affects the carbon forward
she went what do you mean and she didn't
know what that she's likely to learn
more she did he gets on the bus she
didn't go in the process because she
thought about that and didn't go on
about this one case before I bring
Michelle in I have to say this stuff
works you know if you look back in my
think it was 1975 when all of the women
in Iceland went on strike for the day
and they all took the day off work to
process in equality for women it works
out the financial repercussions and it
after the company that would have a
forbid our children missing school also
have some sort of repercussion on
society I think it will look actually
it's a way of them showing how serious
they are I don't I didn't thought what
sort of people so I I thought it was
wonderful well that student said and I
feel very passionately about climate
change as well so it's great that
they're active and involved and
consciousness so it might be still there
she said she had no other option but she
does what they called Saturday and
Sunday they called not to have this kind
of impact but then the challenge is that
where do you draw the line because today
we're coming out of school to talk about
climate change which everyone agrees is
a significant issue what the UN I'm
sorry the US doesn't do there's another
social issue or environmental issue
which is equally as important so we're
dishes but none of them have had this
sort of impact from young people where
they have all got together and have been
so organized to actually protest
globally talking about it on URI was I
so are you telling me the reason we're
talking about it now is not because
they've come together and organized but
we're only talking about it because they
took a day off stole I'm saying that we
would not be talking about it as much
the fact that they took a day off school
made this thing even more impactful I
wouldn't have read that intro if they
hadn't taken the day off school not in
the way when was the last time you can
remember a pupil rebellion like this
many people rebellion as long as it
hasn't the third time it has no impact
yes you know when I was at school you'd
have to have chained me to the chair
sometimes to keep me in there I was
always finding ways and reasons not to
go but I just think that actually we
have so many conversations to capture
your kids on holiday and yeah this is
the most important topics period and can
I bring in a grab from Owen Walsh and
here's what he had to say
the children are serious about this this
is a crisis they see it as a crisis it's
just up for the adults of the world to
see it as the crisis that they see it as
this is children finding their voice
this is children engaging with global
issues this is about young people
voicing their opinions and getting
interested in politics also I know and
is a primary school teacher and also an
eco Club leader you can kind of person
you want to but he's right about kids
find reverse that's why I don't want to
criticize it too much because yes they
should have a voice that they should be
interested in politics but but I do have
a vote at 16 know having better luck
they haven't done enough for having
experiences something I don't know
but but I just don't think it's the
naivety beyond to imagine that a one-day
protest is gonna change anything it's
not like I said it was the women of life
will over time and what you realize is
it I mean I still meet people of my age
who don't believe in climate change they
don't think it's right you see no I do I
think that'll be much less so in 20
years time
because of things like this well
actually I think it becomes amazing just
like if you went back to 30 years 40
years you know people claiming to be
people saying I'm gay we're still going
to a very hard time in life it's not
true today why because generations yeah
and also don't forget it isn't just one
day there have been two and they have
more plan they're not letting us off the
hook and I'm proud of them myself